Star Wars fans may be tough to please, but
the creator of the beloved franchise is even
tougher.
According to rumor-mongering website We Got
This Covered, George Lucas wasn't just iffy
on Star Wars: The Rise of Skywalker writer/director
J.J. Abrams' decision to bring back Emperor
Palpatine for the concluding chapter of the
Skywalker Saga, he was downright peeved.
"I've got a bad feeling about this."
Of course, that website cites only its ever-anonymous
sources, but we have to say, this squares
pretty nicely with remarks made in the past
by actor Ian McDiarmid, who has now portrayed
the nefarious Emperor in all three trilogies.
Speaking with Digital Spy at the U.K. premiere
of Rise of Skywalker, McDiarmid indicated
that so far as Lucas was concerned, Palpatine
was done after being chucked down a shaft
on the exploding Death Star II at the end
of 1983's Star Wars: Return of the Jedi.
He admitted:
"I thought he was dead.
Because when we did Return of the Jedi, and
I was thrown down that chute to Galactic Hell,
he was dead.
And I [asked Lucas], 'Oh, does he come back?'
And [Lucas] said, 'No, he's dead.'
So I just accepted that."
He may have, but Abrams did not.
According to director Colin Trevorrow, who
was initially tapped to direct Rise of Skywalker,
Emperor Palpatine's return was among Abrams'
first contributions to the project after he
was brought back on board to replace the Jurassic
World franchise mastermind, who departed in
late 2017.
Also lending credibility to the report is
the fact that Lucas is known to have not been
totally psyched about Abrams' work on Star
Wars: The Force Awakens, which he felt didn't
take enough chances.
Disney CEO Bob Iger spelled this out in his
recent memoir, The Ride of a Lifetime: Lessons
Learned From 15 Years As CEO of The Walt Disney
Company.
While Iger acknowledged that it probably didn't
help that Lucas was still having some difficulty
at the time with having relinquished control
of his life's work, the creator's criticism
was pretty blunt.
Iger wrote:
"Just prior to its global release, [Lucasfilm
president Kathleen Kennedy] screened The Force
Awakens for George.
He didn't hide his disappointment.
'There's nothing new,' he said.
In each of the films in the original trilogy,
it was important to him to present new worlds,
new stories, new characters, and new technologies.
In this one, he said, 'There weren't enough
visual or technical leaps forward.'"
Lucas wasn't the only one who thought so;
The Force Awakens was criticized early and
often for essentially being a remake of Star
Wars: A New Hope.
At times, though, it can seem like rehashing
the original trilogy is exactly what fans
wanted from the sequels; the only one of the
movies to gamble with bold narrative choices
is the one they most often criticize, and
it also happens to be Lucas' favorite.
Of all the sequel films, Lucas responded most
favorably to The Last Jedi, which was co-written
and directed by Rian Johnson.
It's probably not a coincidence that The Last
Jedi contains the most story elements from
Lucas' original treatments for the sequels
of any of the three films, and the fewest
recycled plot points from previous movies
in the series.
While Lucas has never commented on the flick
publicly, multiple outlets reported after
The Last Jedi's release that the creator had
spoken with Johnson.
According to one of Lucas' representatives,
Lucas was "complementary," and told Johnson
that he thought the film was "beautifully
made."
The vast majority of critics felt the same
way, although The Last Jedi has proven to
be extremely divisive among the fandom.
Those same fans, though, have also taken Rise
of Skywalker to task for being too preoccupied
with course-correcting many of The Last Jedi's
narrative choices and for sacrificing coherence
in the interest of cramming in overwhelming
amounts of fan service-y details.
It's almost as if the vast majority of Star
Wars fans don't know what in the heck they
want, and Disney and Abrams' effort to appease
them would have fallen flat in any event.
Say what you will about Lucas' prequel films;
they may have featured clunky writing, terrible
acting, and even worse CGI, but at least they
were built on a consistent vision that Lucas
stuck to, for better and for, well…worse.
"This embarrassing!"
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.